und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend
die spd hatte thilo sarrazin die grünen
haben boris palmer die linke das ehepaar
wagenknecht lafontaine und die cdu
hans-georg maßen die muster ähneln sich
zumindest hätte sich der ex
verfassungsschutzpräsident nicht
erfolgreich einen ostdeutschen wahlkreis
gesucht in dem in die örtliche cdu als
bundestagskandidaten ausstellt würde er
bei weitem nicht mehr die aufmerksamkeit
bekommen die er jetzt genießt erst die
kombination aus provokation und
parteimitgliedschaft wirkt den passenden
stoff natürlich gebe es in jedem fall
das fassungslose reaktionen wenn ein
ehemaliger verfassungshüter über
charakterliche eignungstests für
tagesschau redakteure schwadroniert
wohlwissend auf welch dünnem
verfassungsrechtlichen als er sich da
bewegt und wen er damit triggert aber
ohne seine bundestagskandidatur müsste
sich die cdu spitze dazu nicht verhalten
aus berlin david gepackt die cdu
verortet sich selber gerne in der mitte
in der mitte gewinnt man war
und so findet der generalsekretär heute
klare worte gegen einen vermuteten
angriff auf die pressefreiheit von
rechtsaußen des rundfunks stehen wir
haben verfassungsrang das ist für uns
eindeutig und da gibt es auch keinen
zweifel das problem für die cdu ist dass
ausgerechnet einer der ihren fragwürdige
ansichten über journalisten verbreitet
hatte der thüringer cdu direktkandidaten
maßen hatte am wochenende wieder mal für
einen eklat gesorgt in einem interview
wirft er ndr journalistin verbindungen
zur linksextremen szene vor das wirklich
auch eine untersuchung führt dass auch
die biografie von einigen redakteuren
mal auf den prüfstand gestellt wird ob
diese leute die charakterliche
eigenschaft haben auch in der tagesschau
die tagesschau durch redaktionen zu
begleiten
später ein leichtes zurückrudern bei
twitter eine gesinnungs kontrolle
journalistischer arbeit durch die
politik dürfe es nicht geben
die frage ob die gesinnung von nasen
wiederum zur cdu passt spaltet die
partei wieder
für die cdu deutschlands für die cdu
niedersachsen ist ganz klar wir grenzen
uns von allen tendenzen die nicht fest
auf unserem fundament nämlich unserem
grundgesetz und den werten der union
stehen ab wer diese nicht teilt muss als
kandidat erst gar nicht antreten andere
gehen weiter ein cdu europaabgeordneter
nennt maßen einen selbst radikalisierten
verbitterten mann ein cdu
landesfraktionschef fühlt sich an
dunkelste zeiten erinnert fordert masons
rücktritt und ein ehemaliger
generalsekretär gar ein
parteiausschlussverfahren auch im
wahlkampf
während parteichef flasche selbst heute
mal wieder gar nicht öffentlich zum fall
maßen redet reden andere für ihn das
problem klein
ich finde da muss sich der
bundesvorsitzende nicht dazu äußern gibt
viele äußerungen nicht alles muss man
kommentieren wer maßen ist jemand der
ganz ganz weit rechts von der cdu steht
aber bislang war alles das was er
gemacht hat sicherlich so dass es noch
so eben im cdu spektrum passt was passt
ins cdu spektrum was ist zu weit rechts
extrem rechts maßen tänzelt auf dieser
roten linie seit jahren provokationen
entgleisung beschwichtigungen die
extremismus forscherinnen julia ebner
sieht eine art methode maßen auch in der
vergangenheit immer wieder das vokabular
und die internen codes von rechten
gruppen und verschwörungstheoretiker
gruppen verwendet hat also zum beispiel
great reset globalisten oder die neue
weltordnung und auch hier jetzt mit
dieser letzten aussage spielte
eigentlich extremistischen und
antidemokratischen bewegungen der hände
indem er ihr bild einer lügen presse
nochmal propagiert maßen ist nicht die
einzige offene flanke ganz rechts die
sogenannte werte union ist unter ihrem
neuen chef max otte längst plattform und
nährboden für verschwörungstheorien
rechten artikeln
die rotte wenige wochen vor seiner wahl
bei einer so genannten querdenken die
[Musik]
direkt in die diktatur und deswegen
stehen wir da eben währung sind nicht
mehr position wir sind im widerstand
friedrich merz ruft zum austritt auf
funktionäre verlassen die werte union
mancher sieht volkes nationalistische
tendenzen dennoch glaube wir sollten den
nicht mehr aufmerksamkeit schenken wie
es wert ist und nach allem was ich
wahrnehme legen die sich gerade selbst
laschet selbst hält sich zurück man
könnte es wohl führen von hinten nennen
aussitzen oder führungs verweigerung die
cdu geht in die heiße wahlkampfphase und
sucht dabei ihren kompass zwischen maßen
und mitte in sachen corona ist
großbritannien jahr von anfang an eigene
wege gegangen die sich von den meisten
anderen europäischen ländern deutlich
unterschieden
erst setzte die johnson regierung auf
eine durchseuchung strategie und zog
dann hast dich die reißleine
als klar wurde dass das bei einem
unbekannten virus tierischen ursprungs
keine gute idee ist
dann setzte sie auf massenhafte
erstimpfungen das wirkte zwar erhöhte
aber auch den mutations druck auf das
virus inzwischen bestimmt aber nicht
mehr die britische mutante das
infektionsgeschehen sondern die
mutmaßlich aus indien eingeschleppt
delta variante die zahlen gehen in
großbritannien aktuell durch die decke
mehr als 20.000 infektionen am tag
incidents über 200 trotzdem bild boris
johnson am 19 juli sämtliche corona
maßnahmen für england aufheben
beschränkungen für die stadien in
wembley oder wimmelnden gibt es eh kaum
aus london berichtet andreas stamm
wer den fans verdenken seit 55 jahren
ohne titel nun so kurz davor halbfinale
zwei mögliche heimspiele in wembley vor
der brust fußball england im rausch
erstmals mehr als 60.000 zuschauer
werden wembley am mittwoch im spiel
gegen dänemark erzittern lassen nicht
ganz volles haus das tut man sich
dagegen den woche zwei in wimbledon bei
den spielen auf dem centre court und auf
dem platz nummer eins dürfen nun alle
sitze restlos belegt werden
hier nehmen sich alle fußballfans sind
anders rüpelhafter sie trinken mehr
singen wimbledon ist da eher
mittelklasse ich bin überrascht wie voll
es ist aber einmal drin bin ich
entspannt hat corona fast vergessen
seine große sportveranstaltungen als
test event mit immer mehr zuschauern
obwohl sich tausende fans vor allem beim
fußball nachweislich angesteckt haben
was ein wenig an die regierung erinnert
trotz immer mehr neuinfektionen sollen
in zwei wochen alle corona
beschränkungen aufgehoben werden sogar
masken pflicht und abstandsgebot
wegfallen
obwohl man bis zum 19 juli mit 50.000
neuinfektionen täglich rechnet diese
pandemie ist noch nicht zu ende und wir
müssen uns damit vertraut machen dass es
mehr corona tote geben wird dass wir die
öffnung trotzdem wie geplant
vorantreiben können in einer situation
in der wir sonst richtung locker und
gehen würden das hat nur einen grund
dass weiterhin funktionierende programm
50 prozent aller briten sind zweifach
geimpft was einen hohen schutz vor der
delta variante bringt und dieser
schutzwall zeigt wirkung während die
tägliche fallzahl auf mehr als 27.000
gestiegen ist bleibt die zahl der
schweren verläufe mit einweisung ins
krankenhaus kaum verändert auf niedrigem
niveau
für kritiker ist die komplette öffnung
ein experiment mit ungewissem ausgang
ausgetragen auf dem rücken der 50
prozent noch nicht oder unvollständig
geimpfte vor allem das masken tragen sei
günstig effektiv und gelerntes verhalten
man schütze sich und andere
seit die pflicht etwa an weiterführenden
schulen im mai abgeschafft wurde sind
die fallzahlen dort
stark gestiegen die nirgendwo vergangene
woche waren mehr als 300.000 schüler in
england entweder krank oder in corona
kontakt isolation
jede einzelne ansteckung erhöht die
chance dass eine variante entsteht meine
sorge ist dass irgendwann ein
infiziertes kind seine geimpften eltern
anstecken wird sich so eine mutation
durchsetzt die uns in ein paar monaten
in eine sehr viel schlechtere situation
bringen könnte dazu käme so kegel
millionen dem risiko longo wird
auszusetzen sei verantwortungslos
während laut nationalem statistikamt
schon bis zu eine million menschen
darunter litten
ein viertel davon jünger als 35 alles
öffnen mitten in einer sich aufbauenden
welle ein wagnis und sollte boris
johnson der mut verlassen ein
hintertürchen ließ er sich offen mit
blick auf die dann vorhandenen zahlen
soll erst nächste woche final
entschieden werden ob sein plan wirklich
umgesetzt wird
portugal macht zu großbritannien macht
auf größer könnten die unterschiede im
umgang mit dem virus kaum sein
das wird eine art groß angelegtes
feldexperiment dass die britische
regierung dadurch führt genügen rund 50
prozent vollständig geimpft um der del
tabelle stand zu halten
wird es neue mutanten geben die dann von
großbritannien aus in andere länder
übertragen werden
prognosen sind schwierig auch haben
instanzen und infektionszahlen dank der
impfungen nicht mehr die gleiche
aussagekraft in israel steigen die
zahlen auch wieder aber
krankenhauseinweisungen und todesfälle
sind bislang noch niedrig geblieben
die neue virusvariante rauscht dort vor
allem durch die schulen wie in
deutschland über den umgang mit delta
debattiert wird berichtet andreas weise
magdeburg sachsen anhalt am wochenende
gab es hier mal wieder eine neuinfektion
vorher lange inzidenz 0
doch das gesundheitsamt der
landeshauptstadt ist vorbereitet die
telefonzentrale wo normalerweise die
nachverfolgung der neuinfektionen
stattfindet vergleichsweise ruhig sollte
die delta variante jedoch massenhaft
auftreten können sie hier ganz schnell
wieder hochfahren so der amtsarzt
es ist noch ein bisschen ein zwiespalt
einerseits hören wir überall delta delta
und es wird doch ein bisschen unruhe
geschürt wenn man in die medien guckt
andererseits haben wir keine fälle und
das der bevölkerung klar zu machen dass
wir hier doch aufpassen müssen das ist
ein schwieriges unterfangen
die delta variante ansteckender ja aber
auch gefährlicher mehr intensiv
patienten oder gar tote bisher ist das
noch nicht absehbar natürlich ist durch
eine steigende zahl an neuinfektionen
wie sie jetzt gerade auch in england
wieder stattfindet insgesamt damit zu
rechnen dass auch wieder mehr personen
in die intensivstation und versterben
werden auf die intensivstation com und
sterben werden aber das ist noch nicht
abschließend geklärt ob sie wirklich
insgesamt deutlich auch aggressiver ist
was den klinischen verlauf angeht
ein vorteil gerade risikogruppen sind
hierzulande quasi durch geimpft und auch
wenn in großbritannien und anderswo die
zahlen steigen keinen grund nervös zu
werden oder gar auflockerungen zu
verzichten so der chef der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung
gut wir haben bisher noch nicht
allzuviel gelockert also dass die briten
ja deutlich weiter und aktuell werden
die zum 19 juli alles aufmachen weil sie
eben feststellen trotz steigender
instituts zahlen haben sie nicht mehr
kranke das muss man ja sehen ich
appelliere dringend dafür sich impfen zu
lassen das ist das wirkungsvollste auch
gegen data und dann glaube ich braucht
uns nicht wirklich bange sein deshalb
dass wir trotzdem wachsam bleiben das
ist ja klar
im video gespräch plädiert er dafür wenn
alle hierzulande eine eben chance haben
auch alle corona maßnahmen wegfallen zu
lassen
dann kann jeder individuell für sich
immer noch entscheiden ob er eine maske
tragen will wenn sie irgendwo zu eng
wird oder weil er sich nicht impfen
lassen will
das ist aber dann eine persönliche
entscheidung ich glaube dann kann man
nicht pauschal corona maßnahmen auf
die entstanden sind als man keine
impfung hatte klar weiterhin das virus
wird durch aerosole über die luft
übertragen führende forscher auf diesem
gebiet wie gerhard scheuch sehen auch
jetzt kaum probleme im freien
andere fragen für ihn noch nicht
ausreichend geklärt
es könnte nun sein weil sie ja
ansteckender ist könnte es sein dass die
dosis die ein anderer abbekommen muss um
sich zu infizieren geringer ist aber
auch das ist noch nicht bekannt es
könnte genauso gut sein dass die
menschen einfach länger infektiösen bei
einem sind sich aber alle einig
vollständiger impfschutz hilft auf jeden
fall im kampf gegen die delta variante
jetzt am abend kam übrigens noch die
meldung dass die bundesregierung mehrere
virusvarianten gebiete wieder herunter
stuft darunter großbritannien und
portugal damit gehen lockerungen der
reisebeschränkungen einher
mehr infos rund um corona finden sie auf
zdf heute.de von mit dem thema geht es
jetzt auch eine nachricht noch bei
bereits die bundesregierung hat sich
gegen sanktionen für sogenannte
impftermin schwenzer ausgesprochen
am wochenende war eine diskussion über
strafen für solche fälle aufgekommen
regierungssprecher seibert appellierte
an diejenigen die einen termin nicht
einhalten abzusagen die bundesregierung
habe aber keine planungen für
strafzahlungen für nicht abgesagte
termine und seibert rief dazu auf sich
impfen zu lassen
in den usa machte us-präsident beiden
die impfbereitschaft zu einem der themen
seiner ansprache zum gestrigen
unabhängigkeitstag
er sagte wenn sie noch nicht geimpft
sind tun sie es und erklärte dank der
impfkampagne seien die usa näher dran
als je zuvor ihre unabhängigkeit von dem
tod ihres zu erklären
das ziel das ist gestern 70 prozent
aller erwachsenen mindestens eine
impfdosis erhalten haben sollten wurde
mit 67 prozent knapp nicht erreicht
bundeskanzlerin merkel und der
französische präsident makro haben in
einer video-konferenz mit dem
chinesischen präsidenten jiang qing
unter anderem über die beziehungen
zwischen der eu und china gesprochen
hier gab es jüngst spannungen etwa wegen
der kritik an peking im umgang mit der
minderheit der uiguren
außerdem ging es um handels- und
umweltthemen sowie die zusammenarbeit im
kampf gegen die korona pandemie in
peking hieß es präsident habe eine
engere zusammenarbeit angeregt um
globale probleme besser zu lösen
das niederländische königspaar maxima
und willem-alexander besucht für drei
tage berlin vor schloss bellevue
empfehlen bundespräsident steinmeier die
staatsgäste
am nachmittag stand ein besuch des anne
frank zentrums und des robert koch
instituts mit gesundheitsminister sparen
auf dem programm
morgen trifft das königspaar die
kanzlerin mit dem ungarischen
ministerpräsidenten viktor orban steht
erstmals ein regierungschef eines
eu-landes bei reporter ohne grenzen auf
deren liste der größten feinde der
pressefreiheit
seit seiner wahl greife orban
pluralismus und die unabhängigkeit der
medien an teilte die
journalistenorganisation mit aktuell
umfasst die liste 37 staats und
regierungschefs und chefinnen darunter
brasiliens präsident ball so nahe und
die regierungschefin von hongkong carey
in miami ist das vor eineinhalb wochen
teilweise eingestürzten wohnhaus
komplett abgerissen worden
die kontrollierte sprengung der
zwölfstöckigen gebäude ruine wurde
vorgezogen weil ein tropensturm am abend
auf florida treffen soll
einsatzkräfte haben anschließend die
suche nach verschütteten wieder
aufgenommen und drei weitere opfer in
den trümmern entdeckt damit steigt die
offizielle zahl der toten auf 27 118
menschen werden noch vermisst
hoffentlich interessierte euch noch nach
der pandemie für uns was ist von
menschen die in der pflege arbeiten
immer wieder zu hören
nicht selten auch mit einer portion
bitterkeit tenor klatschen allein hilft
uns nicht schon vor corona war die
situation in vielen einrichtungen und
kliniken schwierig ohne die vielen
ausländischen kräfte würde es gar nicht
gehen
die korona krise hat insofern ein
brennglas auf einen lebens- und
arbeitsbereiche gerichtet der früher
oder später wohl jeden in der
ein oder anderen form betrifft sei es
dass man krank wird sei es dass man
selbst oder die eltern nicht mehr
alleine wohnen können und
pflegebedürftig werden
der bedarf an pflegekräften wird mit
sicherheit nicht weniger werden
damit wird sich diese woche auch die
zweitägige digital messe zur altenpflege
befassen moleküle berichtet jahrelang
hat patrick mayer als altenpfleger
gearbeitet er wollte etwas tun gegen die
unzufriedenheit in diesem job eine app
hatte entwickelt ein bewertungsportal
für pflegekräfte pünktlich zur
virtuellen altenpflege messe die morgen
beginnt er hofft dass sich dadurch die
arbeitssituation verbessert vor allem
jetzt nach dem höhepunkt der pandemie
paket ist ein bisschen lavendel applaus
aber so wirklich für die pflegebranche
für die pflegekraft die am bett stehen
hat sich nahezu gar nichts verändert und
dafür auch noch für einen hungerlohn das
wertschätzung unterste grenze und um die
wirklich guten arbeitgeber hervorzuheben
habe ich halt die plattform gegründet um
mehr transparenz in die pflegebranche
aber um rein zu bringen
andrea recke gefällt es in der awo
pflegeheim einrichtungen braunschweig in
der sie seit einigen jahren arbeitet
flache hierarchien ein freundliches
arbeitsumfeld und es wird nach tarif
gezahlt doch die korona pandemie hat
deutliche spuren hinterlassen
auch ein wenig enttäuschung über zu
wenig wertschätzung
also ich spüre nicht mehr die
anerkennung wie wir sie vor einem jahr
hatten also es wäre schon schön wenn
weiterhin für uns applaudiert wird weil
die arbeitsbelastung ja immer noch sehr
hoch ist auch durch das corona virus
jetzt kommt noch die die mutanten mit
dazu und
die angst bleibt ja die korona pandemie
hat die schwächen des stationären pflege
systems in aller deutlichkeit auf
gezeigt auch wenn diese schon vor der
pandemie bekannt waren zu wenig personal
zu wenig zeit für heimbewohner leiterin
katja maria starosta sah wie sehr die
bewohner leiden als das corona virus
letztes jahr im märz in dieses heim kam
und dann alles komplett abgeschottet
wurde
knapp sieben wochen wirklich komplett
isoliert und dann angefangen klein
kohorten weil wir festgestellt haben
dass die bewohner auch im zimmer ja
nicht mehr so alleine essen das ist ein
grund warum man ins heim ziehen
ich würde es auch nie wieder so tun
monatelang mussten heimbewohner in ihrem
zimmer bleiben alleine essen auch sie
war viel allein die 81 jährige bärbel
reichert ertrug diese zeit der
einsamkeit und isolation tapfer sie hat
schon viel anderes ertragen müssen wir
haben zwei kriege verloren sind
zusammengerückt und konnten uns
gegenseitig helfen
aber hier hieß es immer nur abstand
halten
und das alles weil man sich nicht
zusammen hinsetzen konnte sie
unterhalten konnte nur immer mit
riesenabstand und das war nicht gut auch
wenn diese schutzmaßnahmen der
abschottung notwendig waren während der
korona pandemie es hat den heimbewohnern
geschadet so von der außenwelt und ihren
angehörigen abgeriegelt zu sein und
jetzt nochmal heinz mit einem thema das
derzeit nicht nur die wirtschaft
aufhellt
nach dem hacker-angriff auf unternehmen
in zahlreichen ländern ist nach wie vor
unklar welche dimensionen diese attacke
hat das bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik spricht von einer
dynamischen entwicklung des lagebildes
frank wittmann was kann man bisher dazu
sagen ja auch in deutschland sind
dienstleister betroffen mehrere tausend
geräte sollen hierzulande verschlüsselt
worden seien sagt das bsi
doch wo genau welche betriebe schaden
genommen haben das ließ sich auch heute
noch nicht sagen nur so viel ist klar
der jüngste angriff so der
hauptgeschäftsführer des digital
verbandes bitkom
rohleder stelle nur die spitze eines
eisberges in einer reihe von attacken da
die seit monaten für steigende
aufmerksamkeit sorgen erst vor wenigen
wochen der angriff auf den weltgrössten
fleischkonzern jbs das muster immer das
gleiche täter dringen in die it-systeme
ein verschlüsseln wichtige firmendaten
und fordern anschließend lösegeld nach
dieser jüngsten attacke 70 millionen
us-dollar bitcoin ein rekordbetrag
hinter beiden erpressungen steckt ein
und dieselbe einrichtung eine in
russland verortete hackergruppe die
inzwischen wie eine richtige industrie
arbeitsteilig organisiert ist und
zunehmend größere konzerne oder wie in
diesem fall einen weltweit operierenden
it-dienstleister mit 40.000 kunden
attackiert internetkriminalität speziell
die masche mit der schutzgeld erpressung
boomt die schäden für die
gesamtwirtschaft gehen in die milliarden
frank wittmann vielen dank und zum
tennis alexander zverev ist beim grand
slam turnier von wimbledon im
achtelfinale ausgeschieden
eine runde weiter dagegen ist angelique
kerber die kielerin gewann gegen die
us-amerikanerin korrigiert und steht
erstmals seit ihrem wimbledon sieg vor
drei jahren wieder unter den besten acht
eines grand-slam-turniers
jetzt ist dir alles zuzutrauen angelique
kerber ist auf gras fast schon wieder so
stark wie bei ihrem wimbledon-sieg 2018
die große amerikanische tennis hoffnung
corrie golf konnte ihr noch nicht
standhalten
die 33-jährige deutsche warf gegen ihre
16 jahre jüngere rivalin ihre besten
tugenden in die waagschale
insbesondere ihren kampfgeist nach 76
minuten matchball kerber zum 6 zu 4 und
6 zu 4
dass sie bereits morgen zum
viertelfinale gegen die tschechin mutter
war antreten muss kommt ihr gerade recht
ich genieße meine zeit hier es ist
einfach großartig vor ihnen zu spielen
das gibt mir die energie mein bestes
tennis zu spielen
ihre freude springt einfach über wenn
auch heute nicht unbedingt auf ihre
gegnerin der sänger und entertainer bill
ramseys tot er starb am vergangenen
freitag im alter von 90 jahren
bremser kam als us-soldat deutschland wo
er ab den 1950 er als jazz sänger
auftrat
berühmt wurde er dann mit
deutschsprachigen schlagern die pedale
souvenirs und ohne krimi geht die mimi
nie ins bett wenn sie spielte auch in
filmen mit moderierte fernsehshow und
stand bis ins hohe alter ist sänger auf
der bühne wie werden zukünftige
generationen über uns denken wird man in
100 oder mehr jahren über uns entsetzt
den kopf schütteln
der kluge roger willemsen viel zu früh
verstorben und viel vermisst widmet
dieser frage sein letztes buch eine
textsammlung die erst nach seinem tod
veröffentlicht wurde
unter dem titel wer wir waren in dieser
quasi vorweg genommenen rückschau auf
die gegenwart schrieb er
wir waren jene die wussten aber nicht
verstanden
voller informationen aber ohne
erkenntnis seine befürchtung die
menschheit lässt klimawandel
umweltzerstörung und artensterben
geschehen verpasst den moment des
handels daran angelehnt ist nun ein film
entstanden mit dem gleichen titel wer
wir waren nadja nasa beginnt ihren film
über den film mit einem blick von ganz
oben
[Musik]
das ist was von mir unmöglich verrückt
scheint dass wir diesen kleinen blauen
planeten
der einzige ort im universum wo menschen
leben können
nichts zu tun haben als zu zerstören
astronaut alexander gerst bei seiner
letzten mission in der internationalen
raumstation
er dokumentiert seine gedanken seinen
blick auf die welt von oben wie gehen
wir mit unserer erde unseren ozeanen
unseren ressourcen er keine kriege von
oben sehen extreme wetterphänomene aber
vor allem wie zerbrechlich unser
lebensraum ist
wenn wir unseren planeten zerstören dann
ist es vorbei mit uns dann endet die
geschichte der menschheit
ich dachte ich sei da so vor so ein
bisschen gefeilt weil ich bin ja
geophysiker ich wusste von vornherein
den er durch messer auf den kilometer
genau ich wusste wie dünn die atmosphäre
ist und dann als ich es mit eigenen
augen gesehen habt dann hat mich das
noch mal ja noch mal extra getroffen und
noch mal extra beeindruckt und das ist
das wichtige daran dass wir verstehen
dass diese erde viel zu klein ist als
dass wir die als gegeben hinnehmen als
dass wir uns nicht darum kümmern was tun
wir unserem planeten an was ist
irreversibel wie die atomkatastrophe von
fukushima was noch zu retten
der film begleitet sechs wissenschaftler
innen aus unterschiedlichen fachgebieten
und kontinenten die ozeanologen sylvia
earle seit jahrzehnten erforscht sie die
ökosysteme der meere ruft jeden
einzelnen zum handeln auf jede
entscheidung ist wichtig was wir essen
was wir anziehen
welche energie wir nutzen ob wir wasser
verschwenden oder nicht das kann bei
acht milliarden menschen viel bewirken
ich wollte eigentlich einen film machen
indem ich mal von diesen die auf wir
kommen in dem ich bezeuge dass hinter
diesen problemen die möglicherweise für
uns isoliert da sind wie klima krise
soziale krisen wo man immer zeigen kann
dass man dass man realisiert dass wir
teil des problems sind aber auch teil
der lösung eine forderung mehr globale
kooperation die länder afrikas etwa
verursachen nur vier prozent des co2
ausstoßes bekommen klimaveränderungen
aber mit besonderer härte zu spüren wer
wir waren heißt der beeindruckenden
dokumentarfilm der unsere gegenwart
beschreibt und die frage stellt wie
werden spätere generationen auf uns
blicken wenn wir geschichte sind ich
hoffe dass die zukünftige generation
unsere generation als die in erinnerung
hat die verstanden hat die wissen in
verständnis und bewusstsein
transformiert
der film betrachtet die welt aus
ungewöhnlichen perspektiven mit
atemberaubenden bildern und einer klaren
botschaft wir sind die die es jetzt
angehen müssen
[Musik]
das was man uns mit dem montagskino
geht's weiter und danach um 0 uhr meldet
sich christopher wehrmann mit dem auto
schnell update morgen abend melden wir
uns erst um 23.15 auf wiedersehen für
die sind
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ein neues tief
nähert sich und und es hat schauer und
gewitter im gepäck und die werden mit
dieser kaltfront hier ausgelöst erst
einmal im norden deutschlands und dann
in der mitte und zum abend hin aus den
alpen heraus im süden und im vorfeld
dieser kaltfront kommt auch noch heiße
luft mit eins nach dem anderen sich
schauen erst mal in die nacht da werden
die schauer erst einmal in sich
zusammenbrechen sie lassen nach und dann
bildet sich in gewässernähe durchaus
nebel und die temperaturen sinken an den
alpen auf 11 grad jesus kühlt 12 grad im
südosten aber sonst häufig werte bei 15
16 und 17 grad im südwesten
morgen am vormittag ist es schon soweit
von westen her kommt die kaltfront und
löste heftige schauer und gewitter aus
mit sturm hagel und auch platzregen im
osten deutschlands merkt man nichts
davon da scheint die sonne und auch am
nachmittag scheint dort die sonne aber
zum abend hin kann es durchaus auch mal
gewittern im tagesverlauf jedoch kommt
die kaltfront allmählich ostwärts voran
im süden dann ab dem nachmittag heftige
gewitter von süden her die temperaturen
dazu im vorfeld bis 31 grad heiss im
osten deutschlands 32 im südosten 21
grad in der eifel die nächsten tage am
mittwoch gibt es schauer teils auch mit
blitz und donner bis 26 grad am
donnerstag sind diese heftiger und
teilweise im unwetter bereich bis 30
grad heiß und damit ein schöner habt